transgender athletes I don't [__]
understand that you know I understand it
you know you want to switch around I
don't give a [__] but I'm a sports fan
that's a really New Concept to me that
you can be a dude right ranked 80th in
the [__] world you have your dick cut
off you put on a sports bra and now
you're the number one tennis player in
the world just coming out there with
your man's shoulders
that doesn't seem fair I might be wrong
I might just be an old guy I have no
idea
but I'm hearing rumors like some of them
are getting into that MMA you can't have
that [__]
am I nuts that is a [__] dude
beating the [__] out of a woman
Jesus Christ he might as well hit her
with this discarded dick like a
flashlight
oh still Salvage grounded her grounded
Pawn is incredible
[Music]
bring him to a nice normal mainstream
topic so everybody can drive home happy
no fights all right sound good all right
great let's talk abortion
pro-choice always made sense to me
because I don't like people telling me
what to do and I always just like it's
your body who the [__] am I to tell you
what to do with your body so that always
made sense however I still think you're
killing a baby
see that's where it gets weird
pro-choice people like well it's not a
life yet it's not a baby yet may or may
not be true I don't know I'm not a
doctor but I'll tell you my gut tells me
that doesn't make sense it's not a baby
yet that would be like if I was making a
cake and I poured some batter in a pan
and I put it in the oven and then five
minutes later you came by and you
grabbed the pan you threw it across the
floor and I went what the [__] you just
ruined my birthday cake and then you
were like well that wasn't a cake yet
well it would have been if you didn't do
what you just did there would have been
a cake in 50 minutes something happened
in that cake you cake murdering son of a
[__] right I think I know I think I
know how to raise a kid you know this
you just you just play catch with them
that's how you raise a kid you play
catch with them you just talk about life
you distract them by throwing the ball
they don't even notice you're filling
their heads up with your theories
right you don't do it the old school way
where your parents used to sit down
across me you want to tell me about your
day right what's that Sun ah we're not
going to church today [__] that
that's all a bunch of [__] God's
everywhere but I gotta go down there to
see him really and he's mad at me down
there and I owe you money go [__]
yourself
[Applause]
it's not down he's in here they try to
take it it's thanks in here you do
something good you feel good you do
something bad you feel bad you know
unless you're like a sociopath and
you'll feel [__] unless you got somebody
duct taped upside down in your apartment
you know and if you do something like
that I want you to feel like you can
come to me you know
come to me confess all of that we'll go
down to the precinct we'll tell them
everything yeah I'm gonna turn you in
this isn't [__] Dexter what do you
mind let's have a little empathy here
put yourself in a lesbian shoes who do
lesbians think women who do they do who
do they do they move in with women who
do they get in relationships with women
who do they eventually marry women and I
was thinking like oh my God I did that
I know what it's like to live with one
of those [__] things
I know exactly what that it's hopeless
trying to make them happy hey I want you
to
the shop did I do it right huh trying to
get him take responsibility for their
actions not gonna happen the best you're
gonna get is I'm sorry but I know what
it's like to be winning a [__]
argument you're winning you're winning
you're winning and then they turn it
around they're crying you're apologizing
you're thinking what the [__] just
happened how am I losing this [__] I had
you on the ropes you feel so dumb you
gotta go for a walk and you're just
thinking how did I lose again and then
you figure it out it makes you feel
stupid and then you see some bald idiot
with a giant orange mustache like you
know what where'd you take some of that
[__]
now look I know you're not supposed to
make fun of fat people I understand all
right I don't know why though
why they're not a race they're not a
religion it's totally curable eat an
apple and go for a walk you know why are
you yelling at everybody else
the [__] are you giving me [__] for all
right you put the cookies in there I
didn't
how is this my problem
Jesus Christ you ain't your way in you
can walk your way out all right and just
slowly start shedding the pounds shove
some [__] lettuce in there instead of
a bunch of ho-hos and it's it's gonna
come down
and then you're on my side of the fence
right join me come on stay with me Shame
Shame
all right
I always say my wife my when my wife was
pregnant I said my wife you know she's
pregnant and then I always have these
people excuse me you're supposed to say
we're pregnant you're supposed to say
we're pregnant it's like well I'm not a
seahorse so
I'm pregnant my wife is pregnant look at
she's putting on weight her feet is
swelling up you know she's miserable
[__] miserable I'm still doing
pull-ups I'm crushing it while being
pregnant I'm still drinking smoking yeah
I saw a woman a couple months back
professional soccer player right she
goes on to ESPN on one of these sports
channels and she starts bitching going
like I don't understand how come female
athletes don't make as much as male
professional athletes right and all of
these men had to sit there and act like
they didn't know what the answer was
they had to sit there like dumbfounded
like oh
why is that
that is it but not from I have I have no
idea
literally I'm sitting at home screaming
at the TV cause you don't sound any
[__] ticket
nobody has no it's going to women's
soccer games
1500 people show up that's not a good
night
the promoter lost his [__] ass on
that dick love about sports is it's a
great way to tap out from the news and
just you know watch a game and get away
from it now there's like all these
causes are getting like attached to it
like I was watching the World Series and
I'm in the middle of watching the World
Series and out of nowhere they have this
moment stand up to cancer I'm watching a
ball game and all of a sudden everybody
stands up holding up a sign of somebody
that they either know that's dying of
cancer or died of it in the middle of
the game it's just like what are you
doing
trying to watch a game here you know no
there's a time and a place look I know
somebody
I know somebody that has died of cancer
I would never go to the movies with you
and in the middle of it hit pause and be
like oh by the way Conan
that sheet with two fingers it was
horrible hey by the way I got molested
when I was nine
no I don't know what it is I don't know
what it is I don't know what the [__] is
going on
but I think white women started it
oh
the worst
the [__] worst that's all they do is
[__] I had no idea how difficult it was
to be a white woman in the United States
of America
evidently it's really difficult
[Laughter]
kitchen do you have any idea what it's
like to be me well I imagine it would be
slightly less awesome than my life
did they not chill your rose
and out was the trolley not running down
at the mall what happened
no it's unreal I'm really [__]
annoyed how white women have the [__]
balls to throw my white privilege in my
face you know
start to separate themselves from these
white males with their white male
privilege just like [__] you're sitting
in a Jacuzzi with me
yeah put your [__] whining
look
there's a little copy out here so you
don't think I'm a complete [__] right
out of the gate all right if you [__]
if you live in some Honey Boo Boo
Lifestyle on the Appalachian Trail you
know your uncle just banged you in the
dirt all right so your Christian
background is is part of the the show
yes and I wanted to talk to you about
Jesus after that well the only reason
why I bring it up is some people thought
maybe you went a little too far you know
as far as what well they thought that
maybe you were being disrespectful to
the Christian religion
I'm telling you you need to Google oh
good lord
be disrespectful or just you you were
just having fun with some of the
crucifixes and stuff like that I don't
even know what yeah I mean we did maybe
two jokes it was about that yeah exactly
don't you think the Catholic Church went
a little too far
foreign
they just sort of kept moving them
around you know like those killer whales
at Sea World after it kills a trainer
they'll then move it up to Seattle they
don't give them their background all
right I'm not totally following but I
don't think I know what I'm talking
about it's a Morning Show I understand
yeah
that kid was missed the graduation and
then it was a feel-good story it was a
feel good and we want to leave if you
want to feel good about America you
watch the morning shows you don't watch
this you know and one was joking earlier
if that kid's story about the graduation
was late night that would have been a
whole different story what do you think
he's still missing we can't find him all
we found was his hat but you watch in
the morning it's great it all worked out
he got his own personal graduation like
I was in such a great mood look how
yellow this couch is it's like the sun